Noora is back this morning as we said at
the top of the broadcast she's been gone
a week on assignment for 60 minutes and
this morning we can share that she was
in Saudi Arabia where she had a big
interview with the country's crown
prince people were stopping me on the
street saying where as no I've said I'm
not at liberty to say nor return she
will reveal his location undisclosed
location but she's safe look this is a
big story because as we know Saudi
Arabia is the world's largest oil
exporter they're a key ally of the
United States for the past 80 years and
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman is heir
to the Saudi throne and he is architect
of some of the major social economic and
political reforms that are underway
there he took some bold action in
November when he detained more than 200
Prince's billionaires and prominent
Saudi citizens at the ritz-carlton in
Riyadh it was part of an anti-corruption
crackdown he is just 32 years old and
the Crown Prince is already one of the
most powerful leaders in the Middle East
this is his first interview in our
conversation with him for 60 minutes
we'll be as I said his first US
television interview and I think it's
worth noting that the last time a Saudi
leader gave an interview to a US
television network was in 2005 Barbara
Walters that was Barbara Walters spoke
with former King Abdullah we had a very
wide-ranging interview that lasted
almost an hour and a half plus some
additional conversations with the crown
prince at a time when this country is
trying to reform catch up allow women to
drive etc so it's really an interesting
time I'm curious about what you
experienced so I know you'll tell us
that but how did you get it well I
worked on it for two years
distance pays off it doesn't pay off and
relationships built on trust pay off and
you know I had spoken with the Crown
Prince a year and a half ago in private
about this and it was a matter of timing
before it worked out but there's a lot
going on too especially what they're
doing with women this has been you know
where women that's really driving they
will drive in June women still cannot
drive they still cover their heads so
we've got lots of stories coming up all
right Nora yeah it's great can't wait
yeah we'll air portions of our interview
with the Crown Prince next Wednesday
here on CBS this morning
and the full interview will air Sunday
March 18th on 16